the court commits you to the custody of
the commissioner of corrections
for a period of 270 months chauvin was
sentenced to a total of 22 and a half
years in prison
hollywood reacted with some dismay
director ava dufrene reiterated that
chauvin was a murderer
and kathy griffin said of course it's
not enough time
this morning i spoke with two reporters
at the minneapolis courthouse
cnn senior national correspondent sarah
seidner and cbs news correspondent
jamie yukas both covered george floyd's
murder
the protests chauvin's trial and now his
sentencing
what makes this moment so historic this
case impacted so many people not just
here in the city of minneapolis but
across the country
when people watched george floyd died
and it was caught on camera
i think people took it extremely
seriously they wanted to know how this
was going to end
it's been my life for the past 14 months
this is a place that is
filled with great sorrow great hope
great pain and a lot of folks say you
know justice
there has been some justice now the
court battle isn't over for derrick
chauvin no there are still federal
accounts that are pending so there's
still a long way to go in this case